So let's take our conversation about the validity of field
values a little further and look at auditing a cross-field
constraint. So, remember this is a constraint where we have
multiple fields per item, that must be in agreement in some
way. Once again, let's look at a Wikipedia page for
city. In this case Bern in the country of Switzerland.
So here we have a nice example of a city
that has values for population, area and one for population density.
Any time you have a situation like this, where
you can essentially check at least one field against
another, you have a nice way of validating field
values throughout your entire dataset. So, the cross-field constraint here
is that population divided by area gives us the
population density. And we'll employ this as one check
in auditing our data for the city's collection. So
here I've written a little program to do exactly that.
And it does something like calculate the population density based
on the individual values for population and area. And compare that
to the population density specified within the dataset itself. And we're
just going to make sure the difference isn't more than ten to
account for rounding errors and that sort of thing. Now,
this is just a first pass of this and just an
example to show you the type of thing that we might
do in auditing a cross-field constraint. All right, let's run this.
We should only see output here. Yep. And we've got a number
of bad population densities or possibly
bad population densities. So what I usually
do in situations like this is, I pick one and I basically just
go look at the data and see if I can figure out what's
going on. Okay, this one stood out to me, so let's go take
a look at that. Now, in the interest of time, I've already pulled
this one up in our original dataset. And I've actually hidden some of
the fields here, so it's easier to see the values that we actually
care about in this case. So, here's the area
field, populationDensity and the populationTotal. Now what we want is
for this value divided by this value to be pretty
close to this value. And if you look at this,
you can see that there's no way that can possibly
happen given the size of this. Okay and as I
look at the rest of these values here. I also
see some values that appear to me to be impossibly
large as the area of land for a given city. Especially
given that when I look at the Wikipedia page and as
I look at Wikipedia pages for other cities, I notice that
area is actually measured in square kilometers. So there's no way
I have this many square kilometers. However if I look at
Yoakum, Texas, I can see that it's value for area is
12 square kilometers. My guess is that this is a rounded
value. If I go back and look at this data and
if I interpret this instead of kilometers as not
even meters, but millimeters then this makes sense. Now from
my perspective having a land area specified in millimeters is
a little crazy. But I can see reasons why the
dbpedia folks might have set things up that way. But
if I think about shifting the decimal point for this
value appropriately so, that it describes square kilometers, instead of
square millimeters. Then I end up with a value that's
11.7 square kilometers, which is pretty close to this value, right
here. And these values were collected some time ago. So, I'm
willing to bet that our problem here, that we're seeing in
auditing this cross-field constraint. Is really one of having made a faulty
assumption about the land area. And that in fact is what
the problem is. And now of course, in order to verify
this, we'd want to look through a number of other fields
here. And actually maybe do a bit of Googling around to really
be sure that is exactly what's going on here. And that it's
just an issue of units as opposed to an actual problem with the
cross-field constraint, that we know has to exist between these three fields.
And that's an example of auditing
a cross-field constraint in our Cities dataset.